[Musique]
confirme à la star de la seule femme
appliquée être étranger à la faire
la position de ma cliente est très très
claire elle nie complètement les
accusations portées à son encontre elle
estime que ses accusations sont sans
fondement
elle estime qu'elle fait l'objet d'une
cabale ou d'un complot depuis les
premières interpellations au mois de
février 15 personnes auront donc été
mises en examen et incarcérés pour des
actes de pédophilie commis dans la
région de Boulogne-sur-Mer et les
investigations continuent les enquêteurs
auraient détecté en effet de nouvelles
victimes on parlait au départ d'une
affaire de pédophilie familiale mais
l'enquête pourrait aller beaucoup plus
loin à Outreau près de Boulogne-sur-Mer
6 enfants étaient abusés et 12 adultes
ont d'ores et déjà été interpellés en
fait le nombre de victimes pourraient
s'élever à 30 et l'on s'attend à de
nouvelles arrestations sur place
l'enquête d'Antoine Marguet et Bernard
saids
Gérard le signe procureur de
Boulogne-sur-Mer sort de 9 mois d'une
enquête sordide je n'ai pas de
commentaires à faire dans ce dossier de
pédophilie la justice a plus de 900
pages viol prostitution pédophilie le
catalogue des accusations est
insoutenable depuis vendredi c'est 12
adultes qui ont été interpellés dont
quatre femmes
quand on sait que dans le dossier il y a
des actes qui confient nos salines on
s'étonne effectivement de la présence de
certaines femmes c'est encore une fois
c'est un dossier hors norme on débouche
vraiment vers sur des choses qui ne se
voyaient pas avant et là on est dans un
dossier exceptionnel à tous égard dans
ce quartier difficile d'Outreau tout
commence par de la pédophilie familiale
puis le cercle s'agrandit des voisins
des commerçants et des notables auraient
eux aussi selon l'instruction abusée de
jeunes enfants aujourd'hui alors que
l'affaire éclate les victimes se sont
multipliées plus de 25 enfants
pourraient être concernés
je dirais que
moins une quinzaine d'enfants sont sans
doute concernés par l'affaire voir une
vingtaine voire peut-être davantage mais
l'enquête va le révéler pour l'instant
nous nous avons un dossier concernant si
mineur avec des faits précis
caractérisés avec des mises en cause
évidentes nous travaillons là-dessus
l'enquête autour de ce réseau a même
pris une dimension internationale car
ces jeunes victimes étaient emmenés ici
à Ostende en Belgique pour le tournage
de films à caractère pédophile une
manière pour les parents d'arrondir des
fins de mois difficiles dans ce dossier
complexe d'autres arrestations
pourraient encore intervenir dans les
prochains jours et puis peut-être cette
fois une autre affaire de pédophilie
dramatique sans doute liée au dossier
d'Outreau dans le Nord Pas-de-Calais en
1999 cette fois dans la région de Lille
le fils d'un patron de sex-shop a
confirmé devant le juge d'instruction
qu'il aurait assisté à une soirée
spéciale ou une petite fille aurait été
battue à mort en quête Hervé hardwin
Paul Albert Druon qui avait reçu une
lettre du jeune homme
c'est cet homme d'une vingtaine d'années
qui a écrit à la rédaction de France 3
un courrier qu'il faut prendre avec
toutes les précautions dans une
orthographe déplorable que nous avons
intégralement reproduite Daniel elle
reconnaît sa participation au fait mais
va encore plus loin selon lui fin 99 une
petite fille soit disant belge aurait
été violée puis frappé à mort par deux
individus témoin de la scène il aurait
reçu des menaces pour qu'il ne parle pas
aujourd'hui il nous affirme son
innocence dans un meurtre qui selon lui
finira bien paraître évoqué Daniel elle
a été entendu toute la matinée par le
juge Burgaud un juge à qui le prévenu à
longuement nié tout implication dans
l'affaire rebondissements en fin d'année
Daniel se met à parler site des noms
mais en cause des notables tous ceux qui
le dit a été vérifié authentifié son
courrier est-il pour autant crédible
c'est ce qui essaie de déterminer le
juge de son côté l'avocat de Daniel ne
parle pas le parquet ne fait pas mieux
non et surtout pas de commentaires vu
Daniel elle a été confrontée à quatre
autres prévenus cet après-midi
visiblement le juge Burgaud tente de
déterminer le bien fonder les
accusations des vérifications sur ton
cours et s'il faut rester extrêmement
prudent ce soir ici on admet que depuis
le début toute cette affaire a progressé
à partir de déclaration a priori un vrai
semblable venant à cette affaire
d'Outreau l'affaire sordide ou le père
vendait ses enfants pour assouvir les
déviances sexuelles d'un réseau
pédophile il a été mis en examen pour
homicide volontaire après les
révélations de suspects qui dénonçaient
le meurtre d'une enfant mais les
fouilles qui se sont poursuivis toute la
journée n'ont rien donné le corps de la
fillette de 5 ans qui aurait été
massacré après avoir été violés lors
d'une séance pédophile n'a pas été
retrouvée pour autant les enquêteurs ne
remettent pas en cause les aveux de
celui qui a évoqué le premier la mort de
l'enfant reportage sur place Anne
Mourgues Marie-Pierre Cassignard
ils n'ont rien trouvé toute la journée
les enquêteurs du SRPJ de Lille ont
fouillé ce petit jardin ouvrier sans
succès pas trace du corps de l'enfant
une fillette d'origine flamande sans
doute de 5 ou 6 ans pas plus on a rien
découvert cependant les policiers sont
tant que les témoignages qu'ils ont reçu
sont
bons à 200 mètres de là la Tour du
Renard c'est ici au dernier étage que la
fillette aurait été violée par plusieurs
personnes puis tabasser à mort un
meurtre dénoncé deux ans après par deux
témoins de la scène aujourd'hui en
prison les habitants n'étaient pourtant
guerre convaincus je me demande comment
ils sont faits pour transporter la
gamine
pour amener enterré ici alors où se
trouve le corps de la fillette les
enquêteurs en sont persuadés elle serait
la 25e enfant victime du réseau
pédophile au départ trois petits de
cette école maternelle il raconte les
viols les agressions sexuelles subies à
la maison incarcéré la mère passe aux
aveux elle a besoin de de dénoncer
l'effet et également de faire en sorte
que elle souhaiterait que chacun puisse
prendre ses responsabilités sur les
faits qui ont été commis les parents
comme d'autres de la cité prostituées
également leurs enfants en échange de
quelques billes aujourd'hui 15 personnes
sont mises en examen des commerçants un
huissiers même un prêtre ouvrier et ce
ne serait peut-être pas fini on va
au-delà de la tragédie on est vraiment
dans un monde absolument impensable on a
du mal à exprimer l'émotion qu'on
ressent les uns et les autres par
rapport à ce dossier cette évolution
nous terrorise en fin d'après-midi
plusieurs enfants victimes ont été
entendus au palais de justice leur
témoignage pourrait venir encore
alourdir le dossier et la faire
d'Outreau pourrait prendre ses
ramifications en Belgique en effet dans
ce pays déjà si traumatisé par l'affaire
Dutroux on retrouverait plusieurs
personnes appartenant au réseau
pédophiles qui agissaient dans le nord
de la France Gilles Marinet
c'est dans ce sexe shop à Ostende que
travaillait Daniel Legrand un Français
qui fasse au juge d'instruction de
Boulogne a révélé qu'il avait assisté au
viol et au meurtre d'une enfant de
nationalité belge
âgée de 5 à 6 ans cet homme est l'une
des 15 personnes incarcérée depuis
plusieurs mois suite au démantèlement
d'un réseau pédophile parmi eux un
huissier sa femme un prêtre l'autre
tenancé du sex-shop ainsi qu'un
chauffeur de taxi ils sont présumés
coupables d'avoir abusé d'une vingtaine
d'enfants vivant dans ce quartier
d'Outreau près de Boulogne parfois les
petits étaient livrés par leurs propres
parents eux-mêmes violeurs cela se
passait à domicile mais aussi en
Belgique près de la commune d'Ypres dans
une ferme louée par un des membres du
réseau ici dans cet environnement
discret des films pornographiques
auraient été tournés Ypres
Ostende la Belgique avait manifesté en
masse contre la pédophilie en 1996 lors
de l'affaire du trou est une fois de
plus confronté à l'horreur immédiatement
l'association Child Focus spécialisé
dans la recherche des enfants disparus
ces mises au travail mais sans succès
aucune trace de cette petite fille qu'on
aurait en fait assassiné
nous avons un effet constaté qu'en 98 et
en 99 nous avons été confrontés chaque
fois à la disparition une petite
étrangeait de 7 ans donc il s'agissait
de deux petites filles une venant de
sommeil et une venant de Sierra Leone
mais à première vue ça ne correspond pas
avec la petite dont il s'agit dans ce
cas-ci qui parlerait le Néerlandais et
qui ne serait pas noir à première vue la
police fédérale elle aussi alerté n'a
pas signalé de disparition mais on
continue à éplucher tous les dossiers
retour sur l'affaire du réseau pédophile
d'Outreau maintenant informations du
journal Le Monde de des suspects sont
revenus sur leur déclaration ils
auraient accusés à tort un chauffeur de
taxi et un prêtre ouvrier pour atténuer
leur propre responsabilité difficile d'y
voir clair Patrick fandiau Guillaume
faudra
il est chauffeur de taxi accusé d'avoir
abusé des enfants qu'il aurait conduit
en Belgique pour tourner des films
pornographiques
mais jeudi dernier deux de ses
accusateurs reviennent sur leur
déclarations dans le bureau du juge ils
affirment ne pas le connaître
autre prévenu le prêtre ouvrier là aussi
ces accusateurs ne se souviennent plus
très bien s'il a participé à leurs
orgies pédophile ils n'en sont plus
issus mensonges calomni dénonciation
sans preuve pour l'instant l'enquête
piétine principale accusatrice la mère
de famille celle qui aurait prostitué
ses propres enfants chez les voisins de
palier aujourd'hui c'est sa crédibilité
qui en cause avec des actes qui sont
quand même
difficiles douloureux il est pas facile
d'être extrêmement précis à chaque
déclaration les enquêteurs n'ont
toujours pas retrouvé la petite fille
qui aurait été tuée certains se
demandent même si elle a jamais existé
justice toujours avec le procès d'un
réseau de pédophilie présumé qui avait
défrayé la chronique à Outreau 17
personnes comparaîtront à partir de
demain devant la cour d'assistes de
Saint-Omer les accusés en cours des
peines allant de 20 ans de prison à la
réclusion criminelle à la perpétuité
parmi eux un huissier de justice qui se
dit innocent et qui a accepté de nous
rencontrer Nathalie Coze Jean-Michel
miere après trois mois de grève de la
fin c'est automne Alain Mariko est très
affaibli il est accusé de viol aggraver
sur mineur mais il est remis en liberté
pour raison de santé aujourd'hui avec
son avocat il veut convaincre la justice
de son innocence huissier dans le
Pas-de-Calais il aurait participé à un
réseau de pédophiles il n'y a aucune
preuve mais trois enfants l'accusent
l'un de eux et son fils
j'ai été incarcéré pour rien
et j'ai été sali pour rien
parce que ce dont on m'accuse est un
crime odieux
ma vie familial a été cassée mon contre
judiciaire m'interdit de rentrer en
contact avec mon épouse contre
judiciaire m'interdit d'entre en contact
avec mes enfants en François et Céline
on a cassé ma vie
les faits se serait déroulés à Outreau
dans le Pas-de-Calais de 96 à 2000 les
habitants de cet immeuble auraient
organisé des soirées pédophiles les 18
victimes souvent leurs enfants décrivent
violent et ses vices aujourd'hui la
plupart des 17 accusés ni les faits
dénonce une manipulation face à eux les
enfants vont témoigner devant la cour
d'assises leur procès c'est leur
souffrance c'est ce qu'ils ont vécu
c'est la façon dont ils ont vu le monde
adulte agir vis-à-vis d'eux et ils ont
besoin de s'exprimer pour dire
exactement ce qui s'est passé l'ensemble
des enfants entendu dans cette affaire
et déclarait crédible par l'ensemble des
experts c'est tout de même des éléments
qui pèseront lourds on peut leur de ce
procès en 2002 un accusé affirme qu'une
des petites victimes a même été tué la
police recherche alors un éventuel corps
à outro en vain l'accusé avoue
finalement avoir tout inventé face aux
mensonge et son preuve ce procès repose
sur la parole des enfants justice
maintenant avec l'ouverture du procès
d'Outreau 17 adultes sur le banc des
accusés il est non seulement question de
viol répété sur de jeunes mineurs mais
aussi d'actes de torture un couple et
même soupçonné d'avoir loué entre
guillemets ses propres enfants sur place
Agnès Gardet Vincent Kelner
après 23 mois de détention provisoire
après une grève de la fin à la maréco
ancien huissier de justice comparé
librement devant la cour d'assises
et qu'est-ce que vous dites par rapport
aux accusations qu'on porte contre vous
sûr de son innocence Alain Marie Connie
les faits comme tous ceux qui incarnent
dans cette affaire le cercle des
notables un prêtre une boulangère un
chauffeur de taxi qui
va qui va être démontré j'ai besoin de
me reposer excusez-moi monsieur 2 ans et
demi en prison on a tenu deux ans
pendant 2 ans et demi on devrait réussir
à tenir encore un mois et demi
dans l'attente de l'acquittement pour
que Christophe ce matin l'appel des
témoins a duré presque deux heures il
faut dire qu'ils sont 150 un procès hors
norme qui devrait durer 6 semaines en
point d'orgue le témoignage des victimes
18 enfants au total on va sans doute
demander à ce qu'ils interviennent
plus présent dans le procès c'est pas
seulement le jour de leur audition
proprement dit parce que il nous paraît
important que les enfants voient un
petit peu les personnes qu'ils ont fait
souffrir et surtout entendent les propos
de ces personnes pour pouvoir
éventuellement réagir du côté de la
défense ont dénonce déjà l'absence de
preuves les fausses allégations paroles
d'enfants contre parole d'adultes la
course cet après-midi à procéder à la
lecture de l'acte d'accusation à un
moment pénible notamment pour les jurés
on a vu leur malaises grandir au fil des
150 pages décrivant les attouchements
les viols les sévices un cauchemar qui a
duré quatre ans peut-être davantage
actualité judiciaire maintenant avec
d'abord ce rebondissement dans le procès
de l'affaire de pédophilie d'Outreau les
deux maires de famille qui maintenaient
jusque là que l'ensemble des accusés
avait participé au viol viennent de se
rétracter elles ont avoué avoir menti
c'est toute la physionomie de ce procès
qui est en train de changer la thèse du
réseau de notables est mise à mal sur
place Agnès garde et Vincent Kelner
Pierre Martel le chauffeur de taxi Alain
maréco l'huissier sa femme la boulangère
et son mari tous viennent d'être
innocentés c'est enfin d'audience vers
19h que Myriam Badaoui principal accusé
principal accusatrice également se lève
et déclare j'ai menti ces gens n'ont
rien fait je suis malade je suis une
menteuse avant de s'effondrer en larmes
on a volé mes enfants
ils ont tué ma mère j'ai dû vendre mon
étude
avant de ma maison
[Musique]
ça bouscule
bien sûr que ça me soulage mais depuis
le temps qu'on disait qu'on le disait
qu'on avait rien fait
c'est la fin de la cauchemartre
aujourd'hui j'ai toujours dit que j'ai
rien fait
extraordinaire rebondissements dans un
procès ou très accusé sur 17 clame leur
innocence depuis le début personne ne
parle encore ce soir de scandale
judiciaire et pourtant c'est dans toutes
les têtes même du côté de la partie
civile en accuse le coup
dans ce dossier cette pensée que des
innocents puisque on peut employer le
terme maintenant ont été retenus dans
les filets de la justice et que à la
suite de cette affaire on a l'impression
que les enfants sont terriblement
malheureux parce qu'ils sont victimes
ils ont souffert d'une façon
épouvantable et que ce sera encore plus
dur pour eux l'audience reprendra demain
matin à 9h30 il placera sans doute
au-dessus de la Cour d'Assise un
effarant sentiment de gâchis il faudra
crever l'abcès ce sont les derniers mots
du président ce soir les suites du
procès de l'affaire de pédophilie
d'Outreau maintenant et cette onde de
choc qui touche la justice rappelons
qu'hier la plupart des accusés les
fameux notables
ont été mises hors de cause après trois
années de soupçons qui ont parfois ruiné
leur vie on va y revenir mais d'abord
retour à l'audience et la reprise ce
matin principale information de cette
journée à une exception près la Cour a
refusé la libération de ceux qui sont
encore détenus une décision évidemment
très mal ressentie sur place Agnès
Gardet Vincent callner
a qu'une seule remise en liberté celle
d'une jeune femme les autres resteront
en prison pour leurs proches le scandale
continue
honteux j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie des
innocents qui sont là ça fait trois
heures et ben moi je suis révolté de la
justice
parce qu'on craint un trouble à l'ordre
public où est le trouble à l'ordre
public franchement je trouve la
République c'est de voir les institution
judiciaire qui se comporte comme ça
colère et défiance la fille du chauffeur
de taxi incarcérée depuis deux ans et
demi quitte les lieux en larmes tous
croyaient que le coup de théâtre d'hier
soir allait changer la physionomie de ce
procès il n'en est rien
faire avec obligation de rester chez ses
parents l'affaire comme pour beaucoup
d'autres à briser sa vie Aurélia
Guillemin Vincent Ferreira
soir Christine Martel ne rentrera pas
avec son mari celui que l'affaire a
surnommé le chauffeur de taxi mais dont
elle et ses enfants n'ont jamais douté
ça fait deux ans et demi qui dort dans
une cellule
alors qu'il n'avait rien fait qu'il le
dit depuis deux ans et demi qu'on le dit
avec lui depuis deux ans et demi que
personne n'a jamais voulu nous écouter
pas entendu pas cru pire accusé de
sévices sexuelles odieux la boulangère
d'Outreau a perdu jusqu'à la force de se
révolter
j'ai plus de colère ma colère j'ai eu je
l'ai placé dans mes larmes pendant 3 ans
et demi j'ai plus de colère je suis
anéantie anéantie j'ai tout perdu dans
cette affaire j'ai plus rien aujourd'hui
je suis SDF autant de vie que l'affaire
d'Outreau a fait basculer Odile maréco
était infirmière scolaire quand elle a
été accusée de pédophilie depuis elle a
été privée de son travail de ses enfants
et surtout de sa dignité j'ai perdu mon
honneur j'ai perdu
j'osais même pas aller dans les magasins
parce que je me disais c'est écrit sur
ma tête que j'ai été mise en cause dans
une affaire de pédophilie son mari Alain
marico était un huissier de justice
respecté avant d'être sali lui aussi
il m'est arrivé à moi
et ma peu vous arrivez à vous tous
demain on peut venir vous chercher parce
que des personnes ont déclaré quelque
chose et vous [ __ ] en tôle vous [ __ ]
aux trous vous mettre en garde à vue
et des gardes à vue je me suis fait un
juriez pour apaiser leur souffrance
aujourd'hui il n'attendent qu'une chose
l'affirmation de leur innocence
alors chacun s'interroge ce soir comment
en est-on arrivé là au centre des
questions il y a la conduite de
l'instruction presque exclusivement
basée sur les témoignages des enfants
violets témoignages confirmés ensuite
par leurs parents et valider entre
guillemets par les experts psychiatres
Mathias Hillion une affaire d'inceste
dans un quartier populaire c'est ce que
les services sociaux de Boulogne-sur-Mer
signalent au parquet en décembre 2000
les époux de lait sont soupçonnés
d'abuser de leurs quatre enfants ceux-ci
sont entendus ils accusent non seulement
leurs parents mais aussi des commerçants
un chauffeur de taxi un huissier un
prêtre ouvrier 13 personnes sont
interpellées 4 autres le sont l’année
suivante l'affaire d'inceste se
transforme en affaires de réseau
pédophile mais tout le dossier réside
dans les déclarations des enfants et des
accusés l'un d'entre eux va même jusqu'à
dénoncer le meurtre d'une fillette les
enquêteurs fouillent plusieurs jardins
ouvriers en vain
là on a rien découvert cependant les
policiers sont tant que les témoignages
qu'ils ont reçu sont
bons à l'époque tout le monde croit à
une affaire Dutroux à la française les
experts jugent les enfants crédibles en
trois années d'enquêtes ces enfants ne
sont jamais confrontés aux personnes
qu'ils accusent toutes les demandes
formulées par la défense sont refusés
par le juge d'instructions
pour savoir comment pourquoi qu'il a
mené des débats comme ça c'est tout ce
que je veux savoir qui s'explique au
niveau de la cour parce que je crois que
la faute elle vient de lui je vous
rappelle quand même qu'il y a un homme
qui s'appelle gourmand
qui est présumé innocent non plus à vie
mais à mort et que cet homme s'est
suicidé et je pense que il y a des gens
qui doivent un peu regarder vers le ciel
le juge d'instruction n'a pas souhaité
répondre à nos questions quant à la
ville d'Outreau elle sait que son nom
est durablement associé à la faire cette
blessure là non plus n'est pas prête de
se refermer les dernières heures du
procès de l'affaire de pédophilie
d'Outreau le verdict je vous le disais
est attendu d'un moment à l'autre le
jury est réuni depuis le milieu de la
matinée une tâche particulièrement
difficile tant l'audience a été agitée
sur place Dominique Var Dayan Vincent
Kelner
le jour le plus long pour 13 des 17
accusés qui clament leur innocence
depuis le début dans la salle des pas
perdus ils attendent depuis bientôt 10
heures sourire nerveux alterne avec
regard d'inquiétude à quelques mètres
d'eux derrière cette porte d'où jurer
délibérés ils ont à répondre après de
900 questions mais les 13 accusés
attendent qu'une seule réponse
l'acquittement
que je suis innocente les tresses qui se
disent innocents sont sûrement aussi
voilà
c'est une réponse une réponse
j'espère sera bonne
très bonne
et
il faut que le dossier soit un tremplin
pour que l'on évoque ces éléments et
qu'on les évoque sérieusement ou alors
ces gens auront été sacrifiés finalement
à l'aune des dysfonctionnements sans que
ça n'est meuf qui que ce soit et ce
serait insupportable un verdict autant
attendu par les accusés que par
l'institution judiciaire un acquittement
massif sonnerait comme une condamnation
de l'instruction 9 semaines de débat aux
assises de Saint-Omer dans le
Pas-de-Calais au départ un réseau
pédophile dénoncé par un couple
d'Outreau et la nuit dernière après
toute une série de rebondissements de
marche chaotique de la justice et bien
un verdict qui ne met pas un terme loin
de la à la faire en effet si les
principaux accusés le couple de lait
était condamné à 20 ans et 15 ans de
prison parmi les 13 accusés qui avaient
été disons apparemment innocenté par
leur propre dénonciatrice et bien 7 ont
tout de même été condamnés à des peines
de prison parfois très lourdes comme le
prêtre ouvrier Dominique viel 7 ans de
prison ferme Agnès Gardet Vincent kelmer
récit
vous avez entendu c'est le sourire
éblouissant d'une femme libre et
blanchie après trois ans d'un jour
là j'ai un énorme
poids qui est parti quoi
je respire ça soulagement énorme
là les larmes d'une mère de famille
brisée d'avoir été longtemps accusé du
pire à cet instant la cour vient de
prononcer son acquittement parce qu'on
l'attend en ce moment on attend on
attend sans cesse on se dit un jour ça
va tomber un jour ça va venir un jour on
va l'entendre et puis quand on l'entend
on se dit c'est vrai je l'ai entendu
c'est pas vrai donc
son mari l'huissier quitte le palais de
justice défait il vient d'être condamné
à 18 mois de prison avec sursis pour
attouchement sur son fils selon son
avocat il aurait tenté de se suicider ce
matin car c'est cela aussi la fin du
procès d'outre ou un verdict au goût
étrange où l'on a quitte un père mais
pas son fils
puis enfin on lui a rendu son honneur
tout ça d'unité maintenant moi ça a pas
été fait ben voilà quoi
résigner amer à l'aune de décision en
demi teinte cet acquittement dit
condamnation dont celle de l'abbévielle
ou encore franklavier condamné à 6 ans
de prison pour le viol de sa belle-fille
il a toujours nié injustice Chris amère
et j'habite plus de ma vie je crois
c'est un petit verdict c'est un petit
verdict
c'est un verdict qui est très décevant
au regard de ce que l'on a vu entendu et
vécu depuis deux mois il fallait quelque
chose de fort fallait quelque chose de
clair fallait quelque chose qui qui
vraiment tranche le procès d'outre ce
procès totalement déséquilibré d'avoir
un avocat général qui veut sauver sauver
les meubles par rapport à cette
procédure parce qu'il serait
inadmissible pour la justice que l'on
puisse considérer qu'il y a 13
13 des 17 accusés ont clamé leur
innocence jusqu'au bout 6 d'entre eux
n'ont pas été entendus
les avocats de la défense feront appelés
pour la plupart par conviction du style
et en attendant que les leçons de ce
procès hors norme soient tirés du côté
des avocats des victimes on a une autre
lecture de ce verdict pour eux la parole
des enfants a été reconnue
un certain nombre d'accusés donc que
l'on pouvait penser innocenté par leur
dénonciatrice Myriam Badaoui ont tout de
même été condamné à des peines de prison
ferme vous l'avez entendu parfois le
plus lourdement condamné c'est Dominique
viel c'est un prêtre ouvrier voisin du
couple de lait au centre de toute
l'affaire Guillemin Vincent Ferrer
ce week-end il avait prévu une grande
fête le changement de programme est rude
l'urgence ce matin apporter des
vêtements à leurs frères retourner en
prison
les règles de l'incarcération les frères
et sœurs de la baie-vielle les
connaissent depuis trois ans mais il ne
s'attendait pas à les appliquer de
nouveau une horreur une horreur hier
soir le prêtre ouvrier de l'affaire
d'Outreau a été reconnu coupable de
trois viols et deux agressions sexuelles
pour lui sept ans de prison
la France entière doit se révolter elle
n'a pas du son déception cruelle après
l'espoir du 27 mai dernier
disculper par sa principale accusatrice
Dominique viel avait été libéré mais les
jurés eux n'ont pas cru à l'innocence du
voisin le plus proche du couple Badaoui
de lait celui-ci que certains enfants
ont accusé jusqu'au bout du procès il
fallait aller jusqu'au bout à partir du
moment où l'on considérait que la parole
des enfants n'était plus fiable pour
certains il ne restait plus rien pas
plus pour Dominique viel que pour les
autres
au lendemain du verdict les 1100
adhérents du Comité de soutien de
l'abbévielle continue de se manifester
en nombre
tout ce qu'il faut continuer il faut se
réorganiser il faut on peut pas laisser
faire ça si sans arrêt le téléphone
alors vous voyez
allô Dominique viel réincarcéré tôt ce
matin à la prison de Longuenesse à
d'ores et déjà décidé de faire appel une
seule libération donc on l'a dit celle
de Sandrine Lavier 27 ans elle a quitté
la prison de l'os les Lille tout à
l'heure après y avoir passé trois ans
les maires de 4 enfants tous ont été
entre-temps placés en institution
Sandrine Lavier reste sous contrôle
judiciaire avec obligation de rester
chez ses parents l'affaire comme pour
beaucoup d'autres à briser sa vie
Aurélia Guillemin Vincent Ferreira
contre toutes ces espérances ce soir
Christine Martel ne rentrera pas avec
son mari celui que l'affaire a surnommé
le chauffeur de taxi mais dont elle et
ses enfants n'ont jamais douté ça fait
deux ans et demi qui dort dans une
cellule
alors qu'il n'avait rien fait qu'il le
dit depuis deux ans et demi qu'on le dit
avec lui depuis deux ans et demi que
personne n'a jamais voulu nous écouter
pas entendu pas cru pire accusé de
sévices sexuelles odieux la boulangère
d'Outreau a perdu jusqu'à la force de se
révolter
larmes pendant 3 ans et demi j'ai plus
de colère je suis anéantie anéantie j'ai
tout perdu dans cette affaire j'ai plus
rien aujourd'hui je suis SDF autant de
vie que l'affaire d'Outreau a fait
basculer Odile mareco était infirmière
scolaire quand elle a été accusée de
pédophilie depuis elle a été privée de
son travail de ses enfants et surtout de
sa dignité j'ai perdu mon honneur j'ai
perdu
j'osais même pas aller dans les magasins
parce que je me disais c'est écrit sur
ma tête que j'ai été mise en cause dans
une affaire de pédophilie son mari Alain
maréco était un huissier de justice
respecté avant d'être sali lui aussi
il m'est arrivé à moi
et ma peu vous arrivez à vous tous
demain on peut venir vous chercher parce
que des personnes ont déclaré quelque
chose et vous [ __ ] en tôle beaucoup
trop trou vous mettre en garde à vue
et des garde-à-vis je me suis fait un
jury pour apaiser leur souffrance
aujourd'hui il n'attendent qu'une chose
l'affirmation de leur innocence d'abord
donc ce geste un geste de réparation il
y a quelques mois les 7 acquittés du
procès de pédophilie d'Outreau était en
prison calomnier déshonoré aujourd'hui
ils ont été reçus dans un palais de la
République par le garde des sceaux
Dominique perven les mots ne suffisent
pas mais ils font du bien à déclarer à
sa sortie l'avocat de l'un d'entre eux
Dominique verdaillan Édouard Perrin
une image impensable il y a trois mois
la veille du verdict de Saint-Omer
Dominique Perben offre au 7 acquittés
d'Outreau une réhabilitation nationale
officielle publique une audience un peu
particulière elle va durer une heure
dans un des salons dorés de la chanson
de riz un décor bien éloigné de celui
d'une cour d'acide quelques minutes plus
tôt place Vendôme les retrouvailles
entre Karine et Odile 2 des aquitter
tous ont attendu ce rendez-vous
ministériel innocenté ils veulent dire
aux gardes des sauts combien la machine
judiciaire les abroyés et visiblement le
message a été entendu nous a beaucoup
beaucoup touché et
je pense que tout va s'accélérer
maintenant je pense que ça va on va
pouvoir tourner la page bientôt on va
nous avancer de l'argent sur les
indemnités on va vraiment nous aider
rapidement
moi j'avais une pensée pour les six
personnes qui auraient dû être avec nous
nous étions très innocents sur le banc
des accusés et pour moi c'était
important de pouvoir évoquer il m'a
répondu que ce n'était pas de son
ressort mais ils étaient avec nous face
à ces souffrances Dominique Perben parle
de la nécessité d'un geste fort il y a
beaucoup de souffrance et donc il y a il
y a nécessairement une sorte de de
déséquilibre et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je souhaite participer à l'aide
pour les aider à se reconstruire à faire
en sorte qu'ils sortent le plus vite
possible de cette situation de précarité
personnelle mercredi seul leurs avocats
reviendront place Vendôme pour prolonger
les négociations afin qu'officiellement
l'état reconnaisse qu'il y a eu faute
lourde de la justice
les familles seront bien indemnisées
donc c'est vous l'avez compris ce que
prévoit la loi encore faut-il se mettre
d'accord sur le montant de ses
compensations les avocats demandent 300
000 euros par personne environ 2
millions de francs il parle de vie
brisée reportage garder Vincent Ferreira
Pierre Martel celui que l'affaire
d'Outreau a étiqueté le chauffeur de
taxi un notable disait-on un simple
artisan qui vient de reprendre du
service à 55 ans
je pensais prendre ma retraite avant
dans la mesure où j'avais commencé à
travailler j'ai commencé à travailler à
14h30 mais les trois années qu'on m'a
volé
vont faire que je vais être obligé de
travailler jusque 60 ans sinon plus donc
vous voyez que on vous rend votre
liberté mais on ne vous rend pas les
années qu'on vous a prises il a passé 30
mois en prison parce qu'il était
soupçonné du pire le viol d'enfant
terrible accusation laissez qu'elles
sont lourdes
une certaine peur à moi qui fait que
la présence d'un enfant sont seules va
me 23
les enfants peur des autres peur de tout
Odile maréco elle aussi bien du mal à
retrouver confiance comme elle a du mal
à renouer avec le quotidien ses enfants
les repas les courses elle avait oublié
du fromage
pour le repas de ce soir je me dis mais
je vais leur faire quoi à manger
vite fait quoi et puis pour eux faut
quand même un minimum donc là je suis un
peu un peu paumée
c'est comme ça depuis que la police est
venue les arrêter un matin de novembre
2001 depuis ce jour où son père et sa
mère ont été jetés en prison dans leur
tête maman est allée quand même cette
membrison même si on parle pas mais il y
a eu 7 mois où j'ai été incarcérémo
j'avais perdu ma liberté donc moi je
leur ai écrit de la balle et lettres il
les lisent encore donc je me dis ça ça
nous restera
dans une nouvelle maison dans une
nouvelle ville en Bretagne la vie
reprend son cours une autre vie plus
jamais comme avant un autre procès
Myriam Badaoui à vous aujourd'hui quel a
menti après son ex-mari la principale
accusatrice dans l'affaire de pédophilie
d'Outreau en effet disculpé cet
après-midi les six accusés actuellement
rejets par la Cour d'assise de Paris
Nathalie Coz Guy sapin
j'ai détruit la vie de Frank et Sandrine
affirment aujourd'hui Myriam Badaoui les
six accusés ont tout perdu à cause de
moi tous sont innocents le prêtre est un
homme remarquable dit-elle Lucie et je
ne le connaissais pas en 2004 Myriam
Badaoui et condamné à 15 ans de
réclusion elle innocente les accusés
plus change de version aujourd'hui à
Paris elle leur demande pardon le mal
que je vous ai fait mes mensonges
dit-elle je regrette jusqu'au bout c'est
très bien
et c'est très bien non seulement pour
elle mais aussi pour ses enfants je
pense que ça ça va aider ses enfants
à sortir aussi de du mensonge dans
lesquels ils se sont enférés quand elles
se retourne vers moi et qu'elle me dit
mais monsieur Mariko je ne connaissais
pas c'est vrai que ça
ça fait quelque chose vous savez quand
le petit Dimitri vient à l'audience et
que Dimitri dit pour Monsieur Marco j'ai
menti
quatre ans j'ai attendu quatre ans
les accusés sont innocentés par trois
autres témoins tous confirme les
déclarations de Myriam bedaoui on était
que quatre à violer les enfants explique
son mari condamné à 20 ans de réclusion
j'ai mal pour les accuser dit-il pardon
pour mes mensonges
on est on est contaminé par le mensonge
du du haut en bas de l'édifice ne
cherchons pas à trouver de la lumière
dans cette espèce de pénombre en
conséquence de quoi et cartons à
quittons cet après-midi Myriam Badaoui
s'énerve c'est trop facile de me mettre
tout sur le dos mes mensonges mes folies
dit-elle c'est parce que j'étais devant
le juge Burgaud qui m'écoutait lui aussi
doit assumer concerne appel de l'affaire
de pédophilie d'Outreau les témoins des
fils à la barre mettant un peu plus en
lumière chaque jour les erreurs de
l'instruction la Cour a été bouleversée
aujourd'hui par le récit de Janine
Couvelard la maman d'un handicapé mental
injustement incriminé Nathalie cause Luc
et de Rich
regardez mon fils demande cette femme à
la cour d'assise il est handicapé
profond incapable de se déplacer seul
incapable de violer un enfant déclaré
irresponsable Jean-Marc n'a pas été jugé
j'ai toujours su que les enfants
montaient racontent aujourd'hui sa mère
mais le juge d'instruction a refusé de
voir mon fils il a refusé de me
rencontrer si moi je me traînais à mon
pied un quel boulet d'incompétence
professionnelle il y a longtemps que
j'aurais changé de métier mais ces
gens-là ne le feront pas parce qu'à part
détruire la vie des Français ils sont
tout juste bon avant de des cacahuètes à
la porte des terrains de football voilà
ce que j'ai à dire de Monsieur Burgaud
cette femme est venue défendre l'honneur
de son frère accusé lui aussi par les
enfants il clamait son innocence
François Mourmand est mort en prison
suite à un abus de médicaments monsieur
Burgaud c'est de sa faute que mon frère
il est mort parce qu'il l'aurait pas mis
en prison mon frère aujourd'hui il
serait là
après ces attaques contre le juge
d'instruction l'avocat général réagit
face aux 6 accusés il assure qu'il n'est
jamais trop tard pour rendre la justice
acquitter un mot que les six accusés du
procès on appelle d'Outreau attendait
depuis 4 ans déjà hier le procureur
général de Paris parlait d'un
mille-feuille d'erreur aujourd'hui sans
surprise les jurés ont donc mis un point
final à ce fiasco judiciaire l'émotion
était intense cet après-midi dans la
salle d'audience Caroline Gautier Zidane
percos
Dominique fiel le prêtre ouvrier en
premier suivi de Daniel Legrand les
voici enfin les 6 acquittés sous les
applaudissements ils apparaissent les
yeux sont rougis par les larmes mais le
sourire longtemps
Franck Lavier si peu prolixe jusque là
devient porte parole des innocents
il y a eu des tentatives
de séjour en psychiatrie
il y a eu des douleurs des familles
brisées des enfants brisés
il y a une autre visée
et
tout ce que je peux dire à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui c'est que on a été
réhabilité à la civilisation
dans la salle d'audience quand le
verdict est tombé l'émotion les a
submergé ils se sont embrassés ils ont
pleuré ils ont même applaudit les jurés
qui venaient tout juste de les déclarer
innocents nous sommes acquittés
il y a longtemps qu'on l'attendait
maintenant on doit se reconstruire tous
parce que plus de 4 ans à être dans
l'attente
sauteur de joie
que je que je goûte pleinement avec les
autres elle aurait pas dû être
[Musique]
parce que tout ça toutes ces quatre ans
de souffrance ça n'aurait pas dû arriver
si on avait eu affaire à une justice
raisonnable c'est un soulagement total
c'était acquitté c'est le bonheur total
pour nous tous on a été défendu bec et
ongles par les avocats de la défense et
aujourd'hui on trouve notre innocence
aux yeux de tout le monde pour les
avocats de la défense aussi ce moment
restera inoubliable c'est un jour le
plus long et c'est le jour le plus beau
et c'est pour nous un immense
soulagement vous voyez la sainte Yves
c'est la fête des avocats mais je crois
que c'est aujourd'hui la sainte Yves
voilà la joie retombée Alain marieco
l'huissier de justice réalisent enfin
ses enfants viennent le rejoindre ce
soir c'est beaucoup pour cet homme que
la prison a bien failli briser
sont désormais 13 un chiffre chance ce
soir tous ils peuvent enfin savourer
leur liberté rarement une commission
d'enquête parlementaire aura connu une
telle affluence et suscité une scie
forte émotion les acquitter du procès
d'outraux se sont donc présentés un par
un devant les députés des femmes des
hommes qui ont été rappelant le 1
justement accusés certains en fait
jusqu'à trois ans de prison ils ont
prêté serment et raconté leur calvaire
Caroline Gauthier Sylvain Dauba
on pensait tout connaître d'Outreau
l'audience devant la commission
d'enquête parlementaire prouve le
contraire ce soir à tour de rôle les
acquitter ont livré un récit poignant
émouvant décrivant leur vie brisée
karine Duchochois la seule à n'avoir pas
fait de prison
mon fils aujourd'hui il veut pas il veut
pas vivre avec moi
il m'envoie énormément en fait parce que
parce que moi je suis pas à l'emprison
et il comprend pas pourquoi je me suis
pas occupé de lui entre temps j'ai eu un
deuxième petit garçon et voilà et donc
aujourd'hui il veut pas vivre avec moi
il m'en veut énormément et voilà et il
faut que vous sachiez que même un an et
demi un an et demi après avoir été
acquitté à la vie n'est pas n'est pas
rose même si on essaye en apparence
faire voir que ça va quoi
David Brunet 24 mois de prison
c'est sûr je vis mais moi je peux vous
dire franchement que je me couche avec
l'affaire dans la tête et je me réveille
avec l'affaire dans la tête
j'ai vite de patron en parler à ma
petite amie même à mon fils parce que
mon fils je veux pas le perturber avec
ça s'il a des questions à me poser il me
les posera plus tard ou même comme il
veut
mais moi je vis très mal
je peux vous garantir monsieur mesdames
moi je vis très mal
je vis quotidiennement sur le stress
l'angoisse et la peur toujours tous les
jours
Daniel Legrand 30 mois de détention
c'est le seul à s'être accusé à tort
pour tenter de sortir de prison
et de là j'ai commencé à accuser des
gens à m'accuser de choses terribles à
raconter des choses terribles que j'ai
pu faire dans les journaux que j'ai pu
entendre le garde à vue j'ai joué tout
ça en fait
et de là j'ai commencé à déballer
n'importe quoi et moi honnêtement quand
j'ai vu les fouilles qui se faisaient
quoi et quand je voyais le juge
qui était là que c'est lui qui donnait
l'autorisation de d'entreprendre ses
fouilles dans ma tête moi c'était vas-y
cherche quoi cherche-moi tu me fais
galérer moi tu me jettes en prison dans
un trois quoi bah moi vas-y cherche quoi
vas-y cherche prends ton temps à
chercher cherche vas-y cherche après ça
cherche après le cadavre moi j'y allais
de bon cœur aussi quoi à ce moment-là
j'étais de bon car aussi quoi quand même
Odile maréco 8 mois derrière les
barreaux elle salue l'aide de ses
surveillants
et j'écrivais des lettres à mes parents
à ma famille toutes les personnes
auxquelles je pouvais me rapprocher en
disant que j'en avais marre que j'avais
la haine que il était temps que ça
s'arrête que je me vengerai de tout le
mal qu'on m'a dit qu'on m'a dit contre
moi je me vengerai du juge pour ce qu'il
faisait quand on allait aux entretiens
et aux auditions et un jour elle m'ont
dit arrêtez arrêtez tout va bien la vie
est belle vous êtes bien arrêtez
d'écrire que vous vous vengerez je les
ai écoutés
et je suis sorti de moi plus tard
et puis Lydia Mourmand elle s'exprime au
nom de son frère décédé en prison
et ma mère est morte le 23 juin 2003
avec la photo de mon frère tous les
jours à laver la photo de mon frère
vous voyez le mal que ça nous a donné
mais mettez-vous à ma place comment que
j'ai souffert c'est vrai que c'est pas
Jean ils ont souffert ils ont la vie
devant mais nous c'est plus dur parce
que la justice nous a fait
parmi les nombreux temps forts de cette
journée à l'Assemblée le récit de celui
qu'on a longtemps appelé l'huissier de
justice Alain marico 41 ans père de
trois enfants dans l'épreuve il a perdu
son étude et sa femme voici son
témoignage le 14 novembre 2001 où j'ai
été arrêté ma mère a arrêté de
s'alimenter ma mère a arrêté de parler
pleurant tous les jours son fils en
prison
à la nuit de moi
de moi et ce 10 janvier 2002 qui j'ai
devant moi se dit que je gagne
qualifierais du meurtrier de ma mère le
juju Burgaud
c'est à cause de lui que maman est
partie
et qu'est-ce qui me reste maintenant
un boulot de salarié
et trois enfants
trois enfants détruits
trois enfants cassés
mon aîné quand on vient nous arrêter le
13 ans et demi à 13 ans et demi on lui
dit tes parents sont des criminels ce
sont des pédophiles ils vont en prendre
pour 20 ans vous devez le voir ce fils
aîné
il est pris délinquants
que voulez-vous faire avec cet enfant
que voulez-vous que je lui dise quand je
dis tu sais si tu fais des bêtises tu
vas aller en prison et qui me répond
mais popotes à rien fait tu as été en
prison alors qu'est-ce qu'il va
m'arriver à moi si je fais quelque chose
tout au long de la journée les acquitter
on sévèrement mis en cause les méthodes
du juge Burgaud qui amené l'enquête vous
l'avez entendu le magistrat justement
choisi de sortir de son silence dans une
interview au magazine L'Express il
estime avoir rempli sa mission
honnêtement Dominique verdaillant
Stéphane bretner Virginie travers
inspection commission d'enquête et un
même nom en point de nuit Fabrice
Burgaud depuis son audition au procès de
saint-thomer le juge n'avait pas répondu
à la mise en cause de son instruction un
an et demi plus tard Fabrice Burgaud
reste sur la même ligne de défense
je suis mis en position d'accuser alors
que j'estime avoir rempli ma mission
honnêtement loyalement et conformément à
la loi
je mesure les conséquences d'une
détention et j'ai conscience de leur
souffrance et celle de leurs proches
j'estime avoir agi en conscience
acquitter les 13 victimes du dossier
Outreau ont obtenu les excuses publiques
des plus hautes autorités de l'État le
juge lui s'y refuse ce serait une
solution de facilité pour moi dit-il
c'est là qui admet tout à fait que
puisse y avoir une erreur ou des erreurs
d'appréciation ce qu'il refuse c'est
qu'il n'accepte pas c'est que l'on
puisse dire aujourd'hui faute
professionnelle lourde
mauvaise intention comportement
inadmissible erreur grossir tout ça il
ne l'accepte pas même moi il peut être
critique sur lui-même mais en ce qui
concerne les accusations sans fondement
ça il ne les accepte pas il ne les
acceptera jamais parce que les
innocentes concentre leurs critiques sur
le juge son instruction à charge sa
raideur sa froideur il avait le droit de
vie et de mort sur moi Dilain d'entre
eux des excuses du juge en veux pas moi
je voudrais bien qu'ils regardent le
matin quand il va se lever parce que moi
j'ai pas de mort sur ma conscience le
14e c'est pas moi qui l'ai fait mourir
c'est lui qui l'a fait mourir
il est égal à lui-même ne veut pas
reconnaître son erreur et on s'y
attendait de toute manière
ce qui n'est pas l'intention de
s'excuser ça ne m'étonne pas monsieur
Burgaud a toujours été quelqu'un de
suffisant donc je crois qu'il a beaucoup
trop d'estime pour lui pour un jour
pouvoir exprimer des excuses les
parlementaires eux-mêmes semblent s'être
déjà fait une opinion sur le travail du
juge
burgaudens un certain nombre de
questions parce qu'il est mis en cause
de manière
particulièrement précise sur la droite
la qualité de rapporteur moi qui ai fait
le dossier ce qu'on dit ce matin sur
votre droite les victimes des correspond
aussi partie aux conclusions que j'ai
tiré de l'examen du dossier quand même
devant un tel ratage c'est voilà de tout
le monde d'ailleurs maintenant je redis
il ne nous focalisons pas sur une seule
personne à la fin du mois Fabrice
Burgaud sera devant les parlementaires
en présence des 13 acquittés hier
l'intervention du juge Burgaud ces tâche
fait peu avant minuit après 7 heures
d'audition le juge est apparu comme un
homme seul et inexpérimenté et jusqu'au
bout ces explications sont restées très
confuses Stéphanie déjà rééluk
je m'aperçois que
le juge Burgaud pli face à
l'interrogatoire des parlementaires des
heures d'explication sur sa procédure et
ses choix mais au fil de la soirée les
questions se font plus précises plus
agressivement quand Philippe houyon le
rapporteur de la commission évoque les
détentions malgré les doutes persistants
les mises en examen s'en fondement comme
celle de Jean-Marc Couvelard fortement
handicapé
poser des questions oui comment oui
on avait des interrogations des
interrogations sur
l'ensemble des éléments
bon c'est tout ce que vous avez répondu
sur ce sujet
qui aurait dû monsieur Couvelard c'est
quand même
ces monuments mental quoi il aurait dû
dire qu'il participe c'est physiquement
mentalement pas possible
de bénéficier d'un
c'est nous nous sommes la représentation
nationale c'est notre liberté qui est
entre vos mains les réponses sont un peu
courtes quand même
juge pour les acquitter présent dans la
salle mais les députés le pressent sur
le terrain émotionnel pense-t-il aux
acquittés
bien sûr
tout à fait dramatique
on a pu voir que contrairement à ce que
l'on avait dit déclaré que ce magistrat
n'est pas assez long pas des humanisé
une absent de son esprit la souffrance
des uns et des autres et aussi une scène
rigueur professionnelle même si encore
une fois il a il a répété qu'il avait
bien évidemment pu commettre des erreurs
d'appréciation mais après 7h d'audition
les acquittés livreront aux médias leur
frustration et leur amertume
il a rien reconnu il a rien voulu
reconnaître il a pas fait de chantage
c'est un gros menteur il répond pas aux
questions correctement il a besoin de
son avocat qui lui souffle c'est tout
pour moi il restera un petit juge hier
les a quitté d'Outreau ont quitté
l'assemblée sans avoir obtenu d'excuses
ni même de réponse précise à toutes
leurs questions quelles sont va-t-on
tirer du fiasco du procès d'Outreau une
responsabilité collective dit le rapport
de l'inspection générale des services
judiciaires mais aucune faute commise
toujours selon ce même rapport le juge
Burgaud en particulier n'écoutable que
d'inexpérience ou de maladresse en tout
cas rien qui puisse faire l'objet de
sanction c'est conclusion s'ajoutent à
celle de la commission d'enquête
parlementaire qui présentait en milieu
de semaine ces propositions pour
réformer la justice c'est maintenant au
garde des sceaux de tranchées Dominique
verdaillan
ni responsable ni coupable longtemps la
cible des attaques le juge Burgaud se
voit aujourd'hui épargné par ses pères
un rapport de 150 pages écrit par 6
inspecteurs si magistrats il apparaît en
réalité que quelques plans en être les
conséquences ces choix ou ses émissions
ont procédé avant tout de son
inexpérience et d'une certaine
maladresse autrement dit Fabrice Burgaud
a commis des fautes mais pas d'erreur
grave justifiant une sanction je pense
que l'inexpérience je pense que la
maladresse je pense que le fait de faire
des choix inappropriés sa participe d'un
comportement professionnel qui peut être
critiquable parce qu'on peut critiquer
un juge qui qui qui se trompent et qui
mais ce n'est pas pour autant qu'il doit
être sanctionné disciplinairement pas de
sanctions les acquitter se disent
choqués leurs avocats dénoncent une
justice qui cherche à s'auto blanchir je
pense aux acquittés alors 25 années de
détention provisoires et on vient leur
dire ben vous savez finalement la
justice dans sa globalité a bien
travaillé il y a quelques petits
dysfonctionnements quelques petites
choses que on changera qui n'ont pas été
mais
croyez-nous ça ira mieux demain et je ne
suis pas persuadé que ça ira mieux
demain l'État
un débrisé sur la base d'une faute
lourde
et cette photo elle disparaît dans le
rapport de l'inspection générale des
services mais alors à quoi sert
l'inspection épingler par le rapport de
la commission parlementaire Fabrice
Burgaud et chapeaux foudre de
l'Inspection Générale juste retour des
choses selon son avocat en tous les cas
cela confirme ce que nous avons toujours
dit rien n'est parfait dans une
instruction mais en tous les cas
monsieur Burgaud n'a pas commis de
fautes et n'avait pas s'excuser le
dernier mot revient au garde des sceaux
il peut passer outre la vie d'inspection
et saisir le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature la décision pourrait être
prise ce weekend
[Musique]